let's remind ourselves give ourselves a
review of the comparison test see where
it can be useful and maybe see where it
might not be so useful but luckily we'll
also see the limit comparison test which
can be applicable in a broader category
of situations so we've already seen this
we want to prove that the infinite
series from n equals 1 to infinity of 1
over 2 to the n plus 1 converges how can
we do that well each of these terms are
greater than or equal to 0 and we can
construct another series where each of
the corresponding terms are greater than
each of these corresponding terms and
that other series the one that jumps out
at that will likely to jump out at most
folks would be 1 over 2 to the n
1 over 2 to the n
is greater than
and all we'd have to really say is
greater than or equal to but we can
actually explicitly say it's well i'll
just write it's greater than or equal to
1 over 2 to the n plus 1
for
n is equal to 1 2 all the way over all
the way to infinity why
because this denominator is always going
to be greater by 1. if your denominator
is greater the overall
expression is going to be less and
because of that because each of these
terms are they're all positive
this one each corresponding term is
greater than that one and since and by
the comparison test because this one
converges this kind of provides an upper
bound because this series we already
know converges we can say so because
this one converges we can say that this
one converges
now let's see let's see if we can apply
a similar logic to a slightly different
series let's say we have the series the
sum from n equals 1 to infinity of 1
over 2 to the n minus 1.
in this situation can we do just the
straight up comparison test
well no
because you cannot say that 1 over 2 to
the n is greater than or equal to 1 over
2 to the n minus 1. here the denominator
is lower means the expression is greater
which means that this can't each of
these terms can't provide an upper bound
on this one this one is a little bit
larger
but the other hand you're like okay i
get that but look as n gets large the 2
to the n is going to it's going to
really dominate the minus one or the
plus one or the or this one has nothing
there just has two to the n the two to
the n is really going to describe the
behavior of what this thing does and i
would agree with you but we just haven't
proven that it actually works and that's
where the limit comparison test comes in
helpful so let me write that down
limit
limit comparison test
comparison test
and i'll write it down a little bit
formally but then we'll apply it to this
infinite series right over here
so the limit comparison test tells us
that if i have two infinite series so
let's say this is going from n equals k
to infinity
of a sub n i'm not going to prove it
here we'll just learn to apply it first
and this goes from n equals k to
infinity of b sub n
and we know that each of the terms
a sub n are greater than or equal to
zero and we know each of the terms b sub
n
are actually we're just going to say
greater than zero it's gonna actually
show up in the denominator of an
expression so we don't want it to be
equal to zero for all the n's that we
care about
so for all
n
equal to k
k plus 1 k plus 2
on and on and on and on
and and this is the key this is where
the limit of the limit comparison test
comes into play
and
if
the limit
the limit as n approaches infinity
of
a sub n
over b sub n
b sub n
is positive and finite
is positive
and
finite
then either both series converge or both
series diverge
so let me write that so then
that tells us that either
either
both
converge
or
both diverge which is really really
useful it's kind of a more formal way of
saying that hey look if
as n approaches infinity if these have
similar behaviors and they're either
going to converge or they're both going
to diverge let's apply that right over
here
well if we say that our b sub n
is 1 over 2 to the n just like we did up
there 1 over 2 to the n so we're going
to compare
so these two series right over here
notice it satisfies all of these
constraints
so let's take the limit
the limit as n approaches infinity of
a sub n over b sub n so it's going to be
1 over 2 to the n minus 1
over
1 over
to the n and what's that going to be
equal to well that's going to be equal
to the limit
as n approaches infinity of 2 if you
divide by 1 over 2 to the n that's just
going to be the same thing as
multiplying by 2 to the n so it's going
to be 2 to the n
over
2 to the n minus 1
over 2 to the n minus 1 and this clearly
what's happening in the numerator and
the denominator these are approaching
the same quantity actually we can even
write it like we can even write like
this divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 to the n if you want
although it's probably going to jump out
at you at this point
so
limit
as n approaches infinity let me scroll
over to the right a little bit if i
divide the numerator by 2 to the n i'm
just going to have 1. if i divide the
denominator by 2 to the n i'm going to
have 1 minus 2 i can just write this 1
over 2 to the n and now it becomes clear
this thing right over here is just going
to go to 0 and you're going to have 1
over 1. the important thing is that this
limit is positive and finite because
this thing is
so this thing right over here is
positive
and finite
the limit is one is positive and finite
if this thing converges and this thing
converges if this thing diverges and
this thing diverges well we already know
this thing converges it's a it's a
geometric series where the common ratio
is less than one and so therefore this
must converge as well so that converges
as well